why let me just focus on sociology
because that's something that Jack
usefully raised and it's the topic of
both Julian's essay and Dana's in the
collection in different ways Dana wrote
a great piece about the was I'm sorry
what's her name Lori drew the the woman
who helped her daughter bully another
girl on through a myspace prank and the
girl committed suicide and there was a
hue and cry about internet bullying and
julia's pieces about griefers the people
who bring game environments crashing
down just for the digital well you'll
have to explain what you understand the
motive to be but both of these are
essays about the ethical framework
that's attached to the way people
interact with a medium can you talk a
little bit about well so briefing and
greeters are terms that come from the
realm of online gaming there but there
really a subset of a kind of more
general internet behavior called
trolling which is the sort of invading a
cozy online community of one sort or
another and provoking its members to
paroxysm of outrage and
and break down that ultimately disrupt
the community itself that was the
motivation is well they give they say
they do it for the lulz as the phrase I
wish those of you not specially internet
literate might need to know means we for
for the amusement for the LOL ass good
the great phrase in the essay the just
digital jackassery which other yeah yeah
so for example i have that as a title
for example you know an online meaning
that for cat lovers might suddenly have
someone writing and say hey guys on you
know check this out i just found this
great recipe for kitten stew and
suddenly reason how do you do this and
you know sir why are you getting upset
and you know people get more and more
outraged and until you know finally
everybody's fighting each other and all
those things as be generated I what's
interesting to me why end up writing
about this is is I didn't write about
this form of online bullying for almost
my whole career that the first that
piece that my group alluded to a rape in
cyberspace was about a griefer in the
early days of the internet and 1990 but
we didn't have that said there was no
culture of griefing at the time there
was they were just these guys were sort
of loans sociopaths that's how we framed
them you know they were just these
people who sort of came in you didn't
need to understand what they thought
they were doing they were just a problem
what was interesting was how people felt
with it but as the area evolved they
weren't just going away they were
finding each other
we're elaborating their methods they
were trading tips on how best to troll
and grief and they were elaborating an
ethic almost and so I became interested
in looking at that and and without
apologizing for these digital jackasses
I I want articulated and five
articulated in this piece that you know
what they think they're doing is looking
for people on the internet who are
taking themselves too seriously we're
taking an internet too seriously and
that's the twist but it and what I the
task before me when I wrote a rape in
cyberspace was to convince people who
are not familiar with online media that
these sites were worth taking seriously
at all there is a serious human
connection going on but as the years
went on and I saw people now very easily
taking this all very seriously I became
interested in this you know I've come to
think of these guys almost as like the
Zen master who comes and wax you on the
head while you're you know supposed to
be meditating and your eyes watering off
into the far away instead of focused on
the here and now or is a kind of shock
troops of court jester you know proof
for this social space that is extremely
rich with possibility but extremely
volatile and where it's it's not that it
doesn't matter it really does matter
it's a very serious business on some
level but it's hard for us to identify
where we're over investing and under
investing because it's such a volatile
kind of space for social and you know
emotional and social investment you know
I Dana Briggs Barry
thankfully about all this too and you
know to the extent that these guys are
useful and not you know a complete
blight that needs to rub be rubbed out
which by the way they never will be you
know their utility is in kind of keeping
us on guard you know always aware to you
know alive to the possibility that we're
not getting the registered right you
know and I actually look at the Miss
material from a totally different angle
as a queer kid growing up in the middle
of the United States the internet was my
Savior it was the ability to get far far
far away from my home town and find
people that were like me and realized
there was life beyond small-town America
and so the internet for me was
completely disconnected from everyday
life in all of these really critical
ways and you know I love reading
Julian's reading because it's like
walking down memory lane because i was i
was there when you know wrecked up pets
cats decided they were got invaded by
you know all tasteless it was really fun
um but you know what are things you know
when i dove back into studying how young
people were using technology i realized
how much things had fundamentally change
and the fundamental change had to do
with a level of moral panic that emerged
in the late 1990s and provided an entire
conversation in the early 2000s around
how the internet is the world's most
dangerous place and that you know kids
are going to be abducted and you know
grabbed from the screen a lot all of
these images that you see in the
prosperous where hand reaches out from
the screen into your living room and
snags your kid and I was like okay well
what's a reality look like as I spent a
lot of time running around the United
States talking two teenagers about how
they use technology getting a really
good qualitative sense of what was going
on at the same time I spent all this
time looking at quantitative research
what was sort of going on statistically
and when the particular incident that I
right about here occurred by that point
I was living and breathing this
conversation of cyberbullying and pretty
much pulling my hair out and the
that occur that I write about is was was
discussed in the press as a woman by the
name of Lori drew going online creating
a myspace profile which we later learned
it was really her daughter that actually
created it along with her friends and
the main reason was to engage it was a
fake character by the name of Josh Evans
to engage with this girl megan meier who
was Lori Drew's daughter's best former
best friend and the goal was to find out
as much information about how megan
meier was spreading rumors about Drew's
daughter a whole variety of people ended
up getting involved with this account it
ended up not being drew that sent the
final message but the final message was
equivalent of you suck everybody doesn't
like you you know like you don't want to
don't I'll never speak to you again
something along these lines it was also
it was set by one of the teenagers in
the community and megan meier proceeded
to kill herself the actual case is
really really horrific right it's the
worst scenario of what happens when
somebody's bullied but you know as you
look at deeper into the case the case is
messy and it's messy in ways that
unfortunately are not covered in the
press typically it's messy because both
megan meier and Drew's daughter were
bullying one another consistently they
were tormenting each other in every
which way psychologically socially you
name it the parents were aware of this
in some ways playing the same game you
know go get them you can win kind of
attitude egging it along supporting
their kid as assuming that that you know
their kid was not involved with any of
the bullying that they were just the
victim and we all of a sudden start to
look at what goes on with bullying and
the challenge for me and in looking at
this case and looking at this data is
that bullying is a spectrum of
activities a spectrum of activities that
goes from the the lightweight teasing of
Gino just poking one of your friends and
you know it sort of noodling it's
something that you know kind of bugs
them but you know isn't that big of a
deal all the way to full harassment
historically we've we've only thought of
this in terms of physical form so you
know if I if I give student like I you
know his mom's gonna know you know
that an IBM up in school it was good was
fun but there's a lot of psychological
harassment that goes on all the time
well we get obsessed with the cyber part
of it or like oh it's the technology
that's creating all this harassment it's
not it's the technology that is making
all of this harassment much more visible
to a whole variety of people than ever
before all of a sudden we see how young
people are treating each other every day
in all sorts of environments and it
creates this really interesting
conundrum for adults because as adults
we like to sort of swipe it under the
table if we go if it we can't see it it
doesn't exist right this is sort of this
nice comfort zone or when our forces to
it and what we realized is that we
really genuinely don't know how to
address it we sort of think of it as
just this thing that happens with young
people and what the technology has done
is shove it back into our face and this
is true for a whole wide array of
different issues right the one that I've
been you know head deep deep deep in
writing is is racism there is
unbelievable amounts of racism online
and we live in this great integrated
society right like everything's fine you
know it's civil rights happen a long
time ago no racist problems whatsoever
well what happens when we're forced to
actually see it how do we actually learn
to deal with it and what we find out is
that most people just want to make the
technology go away the technology goes
away we don't have to see it anymore but
i think that there's this really
interesting opportunity and challenge to
actually deal with all of these things
that are blending because the kinds of
bullying the kinds of interactions but
i'm talking about aren't simply taking
place online that's what makes them a
little bit different than the grief
irrelevant they're part of this
unbelievable continuum and reflecting
back a society that we may or may not
like well i wonder if i can ask you to
elaborate on what seems like a contrast
in your answers to that question because
you know you rightly emphasize i think
that the
that what is identified with online
environments or with digital culture is
often found elsewhere and it's just that
we see it more so you think that the
medium are the new kinds of sociability
developing around myspace and other
sites is not significantly transforming
the aggression or the violence it's just
making it easier for us to spot I wonder
if that could be true about racism for
example when people can so easily
organize and they have a kind of
publicity for what has generally been
repressed they might organize in a
different way so I wonder if you I
wonder how strongly you both at position
and and Julian's material suggests a
kind of ethical impulse that is really
specific to the internet and to internet
culture that and it has to do with this
idea of seriousness and with the kind of
ethical conception of the gesture role
of the you know they bring the house
down and and and let's just get out the
door before it collapses idea and it's
not pure destructions not pure anarchy
in some ways there might be a kind of
tradition of Hannah Chris thought behind
it but it seems like more of a
sensibility with an ethical its
accessibility I mean the caveat is you
know I can impute this ethical impulse
to it and I can read around the margins
to to say sit with some confidence that
that's really part of it but of course
any troll who says this is what they're
doing is now taking themselves so
seriously that they need to be trolled
right I mean it's not it's I don't know
it's an interesting contrast I see it
and yet I think you know that this this
space like I said is so rich and roiling
that it's possible for these two things
to exist and both both be true that
there that there is a weird little Eddie
of it's not it's not belong I wouldn't
call it a separate thing just to
separate the phenomena that is purely
self referential to
to internet culture that is an internet
phenomenon per se while at the same time
there are continuities with the real
world that are for to use a very proud
very problematic term that are just
being highlighted or being shone a light
on cursed me that may be one of the
things that we're seeing here that is
probably you know a property of the web
that is that is changing the way the
basics happen is you know jackassery is
is eternal right there have always been
jackasses right that's my quote by the
way for the day and and but but the
three or four people have already
twittered the but you know there was a
rumor that Clay Shirky was going to be
her soviets do it slightly Clay Shirky
phrasing of this but the kind of
coordination costs of getting a bunch of
jackasses from all around the world
together and then jack has were tend to
be like you know a small percentage of
the population so in any given room
there's probably one jackass here right
now right but to get to get to get you
know them to the point where they're
there like an interest group really the
grievers are which is what so kind of
striking about about your piece to it
was hard to get those people together
and so now one of the things that the
internet does is it enables those kind
of smaller groups to self-organize and
become visible to other people in a way
that was harder to do before so one of
my favorite slides that I shown when I'm
giving talks about things is decide from
from meetup com which which you know has
wonderful is a wonderful software tool
for getting people together with shared
interests to organize and meet in real
world space crucial to the Howard Dean
campaign and the main thing since then
but decide I like to show is a map of
all the vampire meetups from around the
country and these are you know these are
not you know vampire fans you know or
like people reading Twilight these are
people who self-identify as vampires
right and it
and that's serious but sounds like a
joke with a serious point is it before
the internet came along if you were
vampire was very hard to meet other
vampires right and I think that's and
that is something that is that it's
different and interestingly I think this
is this is a useful metaphor for this
speak because there's some of it it's
almost not a matter for the space that
used to enable that is the big city that
the metropolis space see this is the
integration yeah yeah the cities were
the you know I mean Jane Jacobs has
lined somewhere with like it's only big
cities that allow like very small things
to like very small stores specializing
in very small things is in a
medium-sized town if you have a store
that sells only buttons you just don't
have enough of an audience people who
are just like I'm only interested in
button something ago but in a big city
there's enough people there enough
critical mass that you can open up a
store that sells nothing but buttons and
you'll get an audience and it's the same
thing with with vampires if it's big
enough city you know there are going to
be some other vampires there and all you
need to do is figure out a way to kind
of signal to each other and get out of
your crypts and coffins and you can make
some time so the Internet in some ways
is recreating that environment for
better for worse and we look out this is
what in some sense what's happening with
you know the birthers with the bomb or
something like that that the internet
isn't allowing people who hold views
that most of us think are kind of
flagrantly untrue to self-organize and
become louder and become part of the
kind of political discussion in a way
that often offends people but you know
that's the price you pay for truly
democratic you know media where anybody
can self-organize into a group around
any idea if they can find other people
who share those values I think it makes
the room for it but doesn't determine it
and that's actually where we have to be
really careful what we're looking at
here because you know like you know
going back to the Dana as queer kid in
rural America I was so thankful to meet
other queer kids and that's still the
story so do a lot of work looking at how
queer kids use technology but if you're
most kid in the US you are much more
concerned about getting validation and
support from the people that you see
every day at school and there are enough
of them right it's not everybody runs
off to the city in the hopes of finding
other people like them and we know for
all of us early adopters of which in a
whirl at the table here a lot of
technology
for us it was this amazing freeing
potential of meeting other folks like us
and this is where one of the big jokes
about social media is that its earliest
adopters are always self-defined geeks
freaks & queers right loving this
technology but once you start to see
mean stream adoption you see a very
different set of practices and so we get
this interesting juxtaposition between
what you see and what I see or what I
would I write about is because I made a
very concerted effort to sort of step
back and say what is a much more
mainstream view of this and the
mainstream interactions is that you only
interact online with the people you
already know that you don't even see
these things you really and if you don't
know looking for them you don't you know
add these amazing conversations in them
in the middle of Iowa when I was talking
to a bunch of kids about about myspace
and they were like you know I don't
understand what the big concern is about
in all of this sort of naked stuff I
don't see any naked stuff on there and
so I started actually looking at all of
their profiles and their profiles
spawned me to do is have a project every
single one of their profile had a whole
dedication to Jesus detail bible quotes
all sorts of conversate religious
conversations every single person that
they were talking to also had religious
communication symbols and all sorts of
other things christian and what you've
seen that is that their world myspace
was a christian site because everybody
they were interacting with on myspace
was talking about about Jesus and you
know for someone who's standing the site
you know like it is you know you don't
necessarily get that image of that said
I should note my action did stand 10,000
profiles there are more references to
God in Jesus and there are naked foot
photos so before you know it's just a
matter of perception when you go looking
for something on the internet you can
find it pretty much anything you're
going looking for you can find it and
you get the weirdest fetishes that you
just didn't even know existed when I was
working for Flickr I found the whole
community of people that made little
voodoo dolls that they placed in public
settings for take pictures of women's
stepping on that with high heels
um so you can find your vampires you can
find your voodoo people um but that's
not necessarily what the mainstream
Internet looks like and that's actually
one of the reasons I get into this
really conflicted you know headspace
when thinking about this as a as a
public space because what we're seeing
is not one continuous public where
people are interacting with you know the
world and all the diversity and all of
this but a whole variety of sort of
smaller public's and the complicated
ways in which those public's are and are
not colliding against one another and
it's so you you get this amazing
opportunity at looking at it when you go
looking but don't assume everybody out
there is looking because they're not you
know the fear that people often express
about this cass sunstein for example is
that you create a bubble environment
there and that and that therefore the
way people form public's in in these
worlds where all the MySpace pages they
see our Christian ones is is missing a
key quality of a lot of other public
interaction which is that you're forced
to deal with people who are
fundamentally different from you is is
that something that you think is is
particular to these online environments
or is it just that we see them now more
I mean we've had three examples
mentioned the birthers racists and the
Christian myspace all all of those are
examples of worlds where people seem to
allow themselves to be oblivious to the
whole rest of the Internet how many of
you have read the big sort of its other
book is out about different kinds of
self-segregation and physical space what
is mobility allow us to do mobility
allows us to self-segregate in all of
these good and bad ways self-segregation
I say can be good because there's
something about having other people like
you for all of this reassurance right
like find finding that other queer folk
finding the other person who has a
similar background to you feeling
validated in human for once right and
there's a lot that's really supportive
that but self does that segregation can
have all the
these other costs and the question is
when people have the opportunity to bond
with people like them especially when
they're you know part of a marginalized
identity group do we stop them or do we
support it you know and so it's not
surprising that we see some of these
online groups come together you know I
deal with some of them where it gets
haywire right pro-ana pro Mia is a
pretty disheartening space which is
where people who are Sienna raxiom
bulimia as a lifestyle come together to
really sort of encourage that lifestyle
and some of the costs that emerge from
that but at the same time you know what
does it mean that you can also see these
same support groups around things that
are much more you know all the all the
health issues they have support groups
like you have a rare form of cancer and
you live you know in in Connecticut and
nobody in all of Connecticut has it
thank goodness you found somebody over
in England that has this you can support
so we see this mix in both ways because
of the potential of self-segregation and
I think that what we have to do instead
instead of saying oh can we stop it say
okay life is going to go in this
direction because of physical mobility
because of digital mobility what does it
mean for this this reconstitution of
society and what kind of worlds do we
deal with as a result this k I mean this
came up in the talk in the radio talk
this morning made the idea of the
Internet has an echo chamber and it's
certainly true there's all kinds of
self-segregation for good and bad going
on but again I mean another utility of
people like the trolls is is they are
they are invading these bubbles they are
bursting them and that's just the
extreme end of it I mean as Stephen was
pointing out you know the idea that
there are no arguments happening on the
internet you know destroys itself the
instant you say it and realize you know
that the quantity of argument and and
belligerence that's going on out there
it's hard to reconcile those two
phenomena and yet
weirdly they managed to coexist all
these things are going on I actually
never thought much of the persisting
thesis I've always thought what can be
focus I I can talk about the second
about the shortwave thing is do you
think that the internets primarily
consists of filters or do you think the
internet primarily consists of lace is
record if you think it primarily
consists of filters then you should be
worried if you think of primarily
consists of links then in fact you get
all sorts of unaccounted-for effects in
fact the major cause of polarization of
the state's intelligent cable television
and also the prescence like regular
impress now these things can be a turn
invented by digital technologies but
they are basically the sourcing but I'm
going to go back to the discussion board
think about these stories from the
selective interested think about these
stories from the standpoint was super
okay Superman has better powers than you
do but he has my super strength a
visionary and he's also susceptible
critical now the interesting the best
technology is the technology makes
everybody see what it does is it
simultaneously gives new ways of harming
both susceptibility right and in forms
of power which were always present to
some degree but never they were around
buying this way now the interesting
thing about griefing of course is so he
requests heart destroyed everything is
about an animated suppose it was the
case that you can walk
I know you are how can you do like a
jacket well not all the East Indies
military jackass in v-space simply
because Leo and essentially what these
centers what these models do you can see
allowed you to share our ability because
he lot of [ __ ] and of course that
wonderful service your home in your
message is a story which go 80 sister
bubble is in fact turns out its removal
may be more than one person and they're
taking turns in the industry before they
all get together and in the room and
they all pretend well let's do this well
let's vote on what so that's a story
about the ability runs a super you can
shake your head accepting the and the
second story is the heightened
amplification of the importance of being
expected and liked and loved by others
right catteries you always want to be
respectable if you can suck it over to
hear community how people feel about you
in an online community example it
becomes the most important thing in your
life especially in fact if you're not
getting any love and then even what else
what that does is it amplifies the
possibility of connection but it also
amplifies the possibility that's part of
the story so what we see in other words
these new forms of available new forms
of our ability
and that in a sense is what people are
worried about their worry about these
new phones of Carnival ability that they
don't look quite right to do it and the
way they reacted as kind of shut down
technology out of course isn't the
answer I think about this way as soon as
you think about that's it for AT&T kind
of a meeting of course pro- Watson
Watson